oh ja was geht hier vor max und herzlich
willkommen zur nächsten folge
mein kraftniveau es geht wieder auf den
server und ja ich bin ich ganz sicher
was ich heute mache ich mache es ein
bisschen davon abhängig ob der liebe
gott mir die gas tränen vorbeigebracht
hat weil das hat er ja auf jeden fall
vor zu tun und ob es wieder tag oder
nacht ist aber der mond geht gerade hoch
okay es ist nacht
wir sind wieder mitten in der nacht auf
den server gesandt bei alternativ hätte
ich mir überlegt gehabt da schon wieder
so nur verrückt oder alternativ hätte
ich mir überlegt gehabt ob wir
vielleicht einfach einen dungeon machen
gehen
aber vielleicht macht es einfach dann
den nächsten folgen so er ich würde auf
jeden fall black magic nächste ein
bisschen was weiter machen das was meine
handfläche verliert man das alles wieder
wenn man stirbt höchstwahrscheinlich
oder tut man nicht sonst hätte ich nicht
schon 15 bei diesem lauf level ok
christiane level 1 damit ist dann auch
der tempel davon erledigt war das mit
mops drin die anteile 30 benötigen damit
man die überhaupt erst mal töten kann
ich glaube ich gemacht darunter habe ich
etwas wertvolles dabei was man sichern
willst du nicht
ich gehe mal kurz runter und gucken ob
die melonen irgendwie gewachsen sind
cool wäre es ja auf jeden fall oder du
musst du uns kellogg's ok und die sind
halt relativ stark die viecher aber die
sieht mich an gehasst hat der gedroppt
auch ein banner cool jazz nichts
gewachsen
oh mann ich weiß nicht was also mache
ich hier was falsch ich habe die folge
noch nicht wieder angeschaut wo ich das
ganze angebaut habe deshalb kann ich mir
nicht sicher sein ob ich irgendwas
falsch mache oder so davon von einem
fall funke ist gome letztens wieder
gestorben
welches aggro auf mich oder viva in
skelett den abgeschossen hat was ist das
denn für ein witz
hey junge macht die augen auf das mache
ich mir nichts vor und ermöglicht die
mobs von heute ich habe so eine kleine
sache noch überlegt wie das dafür das
haus
irgendwie habe ich auch ein bisschen
lust daran zu bauen also ich sags ja
immer ja für die hässliche bruder und
sorgt aber irgendwie habe ich echt ein
bisschen ein bisschen baake einfach so
bei der funke ist es auch so dass ich
ihn halt nicht angreifen kann
ein bisschen stört die tatsache einfach
dass manche mops dich komplett zerstören
können und du sie im gegenzug fällt gar
nicht angreifen kannst ja gut aber also
der wird nicht gewonnen hätten wenn ich
die rüstung an habe ich werde jetzt
nicht verlieren eigentlich living fungi
seht ihr 77 level hunter experience
braucht man dafür
ich werde jetzt nicht verlieren aber die
vergiften einen auch und auf habe ich ja
gar keinen bock vergiftet zu werden
meinte ist jetzt auch nicht so besonders
so eine panne
dafür wich ist kein kann leben bzw noch
schlimmer keine folge riskieren sollte
nimmt jetzt auf jeden fall nicht sterben
in den nächsten folgen weil wenn ich
diese folge vor produzieren muss ich
noch einiges schaffen also ich muss noch
einige weitere folgen vorproduzieren und
keine angst ich mach das ja gleich als
weg und ist ein skelett das könnten wir
es natürlich gefährlich werden wenn ich
das so unterschied ich muss noch einige
weitere folgen
hh
weiter aufnehmen und deshalb wäre das
ganz ganz nett wenn ich jetzt nicht
sterben würde ja leichter gesagt als
getan bei dem motto wirklich das ist was
war das sie gerade für eine kreatur
irgendwas wurden wir grad angezeigt was
grün ist glaube ich
man man man nichts für schwache nerven
das smartpad aber ja ich will jetzt
einfach ein bisschen so lange nacht ist
zumindest noch weiter bauen
dann wollte ich mir auch noch das
schwarze brett vornehmen von von unserer
stadt zu teuer
das muss ich bisher jedes mal noch
irgendwie machen mir die ganzen doofen
zäune anzuschauen wie die fans macht so
dachte ich mir ist es vielleicht ganz
cool
ganz nett so da muss ich jetzt wieder
auf dem baum klettern aber davor
probiere ich irgendwie größtenteils mal
dass das andere zeigt wieder abzubauen
also ich weiß dass das ist natürlich
kein schutz ist nicht runterzufallen
leute
ich würde gerne ausprobieren einfach das
zeug zu retten aber ich hab ich kein
bock was zu riskieren
das ist gerecht deshalb hoffe ich
einfach mal dass wir da ein bisschen
nachsicht habe das ist ja gerade so ein
bisschen rum pussy und bisschen sind
schwach bin ich das noch hin machen naja
ich finde es schöner aus wohne aber ihr
könnt auch gerne in den kommentaren war
was da lassen und schreiben wie findet
ihr das
und falls ich fragte warum siehst du so
unendlich gawlik aus das liegt ganz
einfach daran dass ich gerade
aufgestanden bin und das leben solches
leben wenn man aufsteht dann sieht man
manchmal halt genau aufs krah wie ich
glaube der druck zur experience also
hand experiment myprepaid treten wir als
1000 auf das ist schon ein bisschen
nerven test noch einer ist es mir ein
bisschen viel los hier leute muss ich
ganz ehrlich sagen ein bisschen zu viel
als dass ich hier einfach nur nadja und
brent verliert also klar ich habe leider
nichts zu löschen
dort aber war die viecher das sind sie
mir einfach zu viele muss ich sagen
also da kommt zu viele einfach auf
einmal als dass ich da jetzt runter
gehen würde und da auch so riskante art
und weise die hand experience zu zu
kriegen
zander kommt auf dem server von sun da
was geht hoffentlich kann man das nicht
einfach irgendwie ganz zeit leichter
machen als ich probiere einfach dieses
ständige hin und her so die sachen zu
verlieren
extrem nervig
stirbt usa kein stutzig wenn ein erster
in urlaub auch wenn tag ist wie gesagt
bei euch erstmal ist die perfekte ganz
schrecklich so irgendwie sollte ich mir
vielleicht mal ein paar fragen stellen
lassen aber ich hab' ich denke mal ich
jetzt aber die ganz nah zu bauen können
das hin und her machen können ja leute
daran merkt man wenn leute einfach nur
singleplayer spielen normalerweise nicht
gerne ausprobieren
auch ich spiele immer so mit dem
feuerwehr nicht so dass sehe das ist
richtig also ist das so wie drüben
ok ich regeneriere doch gar nicht also
unter den bedingungen sollten
keinesfalls runter gehen aber usa ist
natürlich auch für das usa fleisch alles
hängt
dort der ganze pc kreise des todes
gehalten so leute wieder ab auf den
server es hat wieder gestartet nach 1000
jahren es jetzt mal so nervig wenn
opengl probleme hat ich hoffe einfach
mal dass die face kerstin kronenwirt
weil ich habe ich nicht so viel zeit
jetzt beim vorproduzieren falls ja muss
sich die vielleicht rausnehmen natürlich
ärgerlich so die welt lädt sie
unheimlich langsam
alter schwede thunder erst noch immer
auf dem server aus statt rot damit droht
sind verhandlungen am laufen kann man
sagen es gibt ja die eine oder andere
stadt die uns alle tot sehen möchte uns
so sowohl uns als auch statt rot
dementsprechend muss man da
wahrscheinlich bald bündnisse schließen
um sich gegen die anderen zu wehren weil
zweitens natürlich zu mächtiger ist dass
man alleine dort da dagegen auch nur
irgendetwas machen kann
ok also am schlimmsten ist jetzt der
fungi da unten
er macht die größten probleme würde ich
sagen ich habe glaube ich
und das wirst du lächerlich das einfach
auf mich weil skelett den abgeschossen
hat also hier ist echt ist es einfach zu
viel
na hier richtig richtig tricky hier
irgendwas zu schaffen
so also ohne spaß also mit ist es so
anstrengend
eigentlich hat man irgendwie da was
gegen machen kann ob jetzt du dich mal
ein usa fleisch ich würde vorschlagen
ich baue mich einfach ein irgendwohin
und baue ich ein so dass ich dann
perfekt kontrollieren kann
wann ich die gegner angreifen so
versteht ihr
so genau
so habe ich jetzt vor das zu machen das
einfach alle alkomat herkommen also hab
ich halt eine gewisse kontrolle darüber
blut ich befürchte das da drüben ist
auch schon wieder der fungi was ich da
sehe ich schon brennt es ist so verrückt
aber ich glaube so auf die art und weise
können wir uns die macht fortschritte
und ich muss mir mal was wohl entgegen
wasser einmal das was gegen das feuer
die wartet direkt kollege ich hab dir
nichts getan
also ich möchte ich nur noch mal dran
erinnern dass das die ganzen anderen
bootsfahren abgeschossen haben du musst
nicht überhaupt nicht angreifen
ok lohn ist kriegt man auch bist du
einfach einen starken sound effect oder
hättet ihr mich noch nicht da hätte mich
nicht okay okay und leute diese smart
beck ist einfach zu gefährlich für
dieses ganze leben alter jetzt habe ich
ein halbes herz
es ist doch einfach nur verrückt ja was
soll ich jetzt machen also die hätten
dich einmal an und du gehst komplett auf
ein halbes herz runter wir sind so
gefährlich hier so habe ich ein bisschen
licht hier bin ich mal fackeln dabei ok
dann würde ich vorschlagen mache ich
aber wieder licht in dem ich hier hoffen
kann hier überhaupt dann rein die da
kann keiner rein so dass jetzt keine
fackeln machen
man kann nicht mehr einfach meinen weg
frei graben leute es ist zu gefährlich
hier aber wie gesagt ich möchte nicht
noch mal sterben und ihr seid auch schon
langsam abgefuckt wenn es wieder heißt
ich bin gestorben
nächster tod so bisher irgendwo
es hat eigentlich auch schon fast so
wertvoll dass das usa fleisch weil das
halt ja richtiges fleisch ist ihr wisst
ja dass wir ein bisschen essens probleme
haben
kennt jemand durch ich glaube ich gehe
so in die richtige richtung zu unserer
stadt
was feststeht ist dass ich nicht ohne
weiteres hier hoch kann wo diese
gottverdammte links ist okay okay in
nature kann man sich auf jeden fall
vorknöpfen ist jetzt nicht das problem
sollte jetzt sehen wir wo bin ich jetzt
das kann ich auch mal weg machen das ist
ein bisschen und kosmetisch und da sind
schon wieder die nächsten gegner oft
suche nach uns so die schein aber zu
wachsen die melonen usa dass unser
todfeind die finther war stressig also
ich hab das ding nicht mehr an geld ich
weiß ja was dann passiert wenn man die
angreift das biest ist auch relativ
stark gläubig aber nur wenn sie zum
schlag kommen logischerweise und das hat
hier gerade anscheinend nicht vorgehabt
bis zum schluss ab jetzt ist es auch
schon zu spät dafür kollege welche jobs
und meine hand experience ja tatsächlich
ich glaube ich auf level 1 ich weiß
nicht ob man die ganzen level verliert
wenn man stirbt oder ob das problem
anderer natur war also einfach dass sie
niemand getötet habe die ganze zeit
möglich ist es ja wäre natürlich ein
bisschen peinlich weil andere sind ja
schon auf einem ziemlich hohen hunter
level was ich so gehört habe
und ist sie flagge des bond ich glaube
ja
wie hätte sie ganz gut gemacht
in unserem haus
aber was soll's damit damit die melone
können ich mal mit dem bauen wir ein
bisschen hoch züchten und nah oder soll
ich jetzt losgehen in den dungeon ich
weiß nicht was ich machen soll also ich
hatte gleich nach start abkommen jetzt
die die gas trainer gebracht hat nähe
ist aber nicht der fall
kein vorwurf natürlich also wenn er
dankbar dass das überhaupt macht was ja
irgendwie will ich fast sagen dass und
dass ich los gehe also nun passt damit
anfangen ich mal an ich bin ja
anscheinend ok troll alle tablet ok
komisch eigentümliche sachen die man
sich hier mitmachen kann
die können wir sogar machten die
investoren solpower bezahlt man damit
meint wenn er möchte er platten magic
machen
das andere problem ist halt das essen
also ich kann nicht einfach losziehen
und hierauf ich erkunde die welt machen
und wenn ich nicht mal gemessen dabei
habe so dass es auch wirklich eins der
hauptprobleme mit dem wir uns hier nach
wie vor leider beschäftigen müssen
leute es ist nicht immer einfach in
minecraft nero aber ich glaube wirklich
dass die anfangsphase die schwierigste
ist und ich bin auf jeden fall sehr
dankbar dafür dass das so viele von euch
verhältnismäßig das anschauen
bei anderen zuschauer bei anderen
youtube ist so dass
wieso prozentual irgendwie fast gar
keiner das guckt und bei mir sind es
halt noch ein paar so auch nicht so gut
wie normales video sage ich mal wenn ich
es mache nur es gibt halt auch noch
einen anderen unterschieden 2 macht mir
das richtig viel spaß und ich muss mal
gucken ob der platz reicht dass sie eine
melone überhaupt hin wächst oder muss
ich da noch was weg machen nichts
herausfinden will dann kann die beiden
nixon machen
das kann man dann auf jeden fall mal
nachgucken wie das hier abläuft so ein
bisschen glas wollte ich mir noch machen
für mein haus schön aber das irgendwie
das prinzip ganz cool auch wenn sie nur
unser hässliches kleines häuschen es
irgendwie hab ich schon ein bisschen
bisschen liebgewonnen muss ist ein
er hat auch nicht falsch mal so ein
richtig großes feld anzulegen
mal gucken ob schuster gibt irgendwie
den man sich schnappen kann ja nicht den
ganzen land verbrannt da hab ich ja
sogar noch größer fleisch ich habe auch
zwei höfen das ja nicht das problem so
und die ganzen körper coins kann ich
jeden fall irgendwann mal bei einem
händler gebrauchen so leute ja die zeit
wird ein amt noch so zwei minuten habe
ich denke ich mal
dann werde ich in der zeit einfach noch
mal das schwarze brett mir vor knüpfen
dass ich das mache dafür mal hier aber
noch mal eine spitzhacke was zur hölle
wollen was will ich überhaupt gerade
machen
ein schild wollte ich machen ich mache
eine spitzhacke gp hatte ich vielleicht
noch eins sogar night falls on the world
wir machen das jetzt hast du noch ist
mir ist ganz egal
und zwar direkt hier in unserem rathaus
an unserem ja an unserem platz hier
packe ich mal an die seite das schwarze
brett dass ich wenigstens
in meiner amtszeit als bürgermeister
eine errungenschaft gebracht habe die
die stadt voran bringt so ich hab jetzt
schaffen so das hat die stadt auf jeden
fall schon extrem vorangebracht
wer das leugnet der hat auf jeden fall
ein problem mit der realität das
schwarze brett okidoki das ist jetzt
einfach das schwarze brett das sieht
wunderschön aus leute oder gibts ruhig
zu so ab nach oben in mein haus lockt
ich mich wieder aus rani verabschiedet
sich hier der hoffnung dass in den
nächsten folgen action passiert also wir
müssen das essence problem erst mal
lösen bevor wir uns halt irgendwie in
dungeon oder sowas begeben ohne frage ok
dann war's das man heute macht es gut
und bis zum nächsten mal